[Music]  [Applause]  disguise  Miley Cyrus took the stage Sunday night  at the Billboard Music Awards to perform  her new single Malibu the 24 year old  kept her outfit simple in a wide-brimmed  hat a white crop top and matching shorts  and boots the performance was  light-hearted and mellow  Miley even got a bit emotional  [Music]  backstage cameras spotted Miley with her  fiance liam hemsworth fitting Miley's  been open about how their relationship  inspired the song  [Music]  Liam wasn't the only member of Miley  squad in town here's what her little  sister Noah told et before the show I'm  so excited for Miley I'm literally so  proud of her I'm getting all kind of  emotional for Miley because I'm really  happy for her and I'm just so excited to  be here with her and like watch her  perform  you